a plane caring Wagner group leader
yevgeny pagosian crashed Northwest of
Moscow on Wednesday pagosian and nine
other people were killed according to
Russian authorities
Wagner Affiliated social media channels
claimed the plane was shot down by
Russian air defenses
the incident marks an Abrupt end to two
months of speculation and mystery
surrounding progosian's whereabouts and
his status in Putin's Inner Circle
here's how we arrived at this moment
on June 23rd and 24th pregosian led a
mutiny against the Russian government
eventually capturing a military
headquarters in the city of rostov
and marching a column of Wagner Fighters
toward Moscow
[Music]
but the Rebellion ended almost as
quickly as it started when pagosian
negotiated a deal with Putin that
granted him immunity from prosecution if
he went into Exile in Belarus
left rostov to Applause
[Applause]
and has appeared only a handful of times
since
after using the war in Ukraine to build
an increasingly public profile pagosian
social media presence suddenly went dark
then on June 29th five days after the
Mutiny despite his negotiated Exile
Russian media published photos claiming
to show pregosian in Saint Petersburg
Putin later said he had met with
pregosian on that day to discuss Bogner
group's future
then in late June and into July flight
tracking data showed pagosian's jet
taking trips between Russia and Belarus
as satellite images confirmed the
construction of a new Wagner Camp there
in mid-july Wagner social media channels
published a photo claiming to show
pregosian in a tent at Wagner's new
belarussian camp suggesting the group's
transition was proceeding as planned
on July 19th the first video of pagosian
since the Mutiny emerged Wagner social
media channels published a video
claiming to show pregosian and Wagner
Commander Dimitri utkin speaking to
Wagner fighters in his speech pagosian
discusses Wagner's new role training the
belarussian military and pledges A
Renewed Focus
foreign
a week later African leaders assembled
in St Petersburg for the Russia Africa
Summit Wagner social media posted photos
of pagosian at the summit meeting with
representatives from the Central African
Republic and African media Outlets
on August 21st Wagner group continued to
Signal its focus on Africa Wagner's
telegram channels published a video of
pagosian in which he claims to be in
Africa and shares a recruiting message
foreign
just two days later pregosian's plane
was shot down
foreign
[Music]